[Music]
he who sows the wind harvests the storm
[Music]
better to be touched by fire than by
dishonor
whoever lets himself be led by the heart
will never lose his way
[Music]
a beautiful thing is never perfect
[Music]
the plant reveals what is in the seed
at the time of a test a person rises or
falls
[Music]
birds of a feather flock together
peace is the fruit of activity not of
sleep
[Music]
admitting when someone else is right is
a virtue
[Music]
the one on shore is a master swimmer
a house has the character of the man who
lives in it
seeing someone else's problems makes
your own seem smaller
the carpenter's door is falling apart
[Music]
the worst things to be in bed and sleep
not
to want for one who comes not to try to
please and please not
suffering in search of truth
gives true meaning to truth
he who doesn't have something doesn't
need it
the beautiful is beautiful even when
rising from sleep
but the ugly is ugly even when they wash
their face every day
experience will show you a master can
only point the way
one hand doesn't clap
[Music]
he who has been scalded by soup blows on
yogurt
making money selling manure is better
than losing money selling musk
[Music]
friendship doubles joy and halves grief
[Music]
when a slave mounts a camel he wants to
ride on both humps
repetition teaches even a donkey
[Music]
routine and prejudice distort vision
a boat with two captains will sink
a wise person has self-control
especially when it comes to speech
[Music]
no discussion can throw light on a
subject if it wanders from that subject
the seed includes all the possibilities
of the tree
keep away from trouble and sing to it
the bald woman boasts of her niece's
hair
[Music]
silence is the best answer to the stupid
love and tell the world
hate in silence
seek peacefully you will find
[Music]
every problem has a solution
man know yourself and you shall know the
gods
[Music]
a person with a wound on his head keeps
touching it
[Music]
wise people are virtuous people
wisdom and virtue are the only paths to
happiness
beware of him to whom you have been
charitable
each man thinks his own horizon is the
limit of the world
envy is the companion of great success
one foot isn't enough to walk with
[Music]
a borrowed coat does not keep one warm
wise people act in ways that guarantee
them a good
reputation there is none more blind than
he who doesn't want to see
[Music]
to no means to record in one's memory
but to understand means to blend with a
thing and to assimilate it into oneself
be patient with a bad neighbor he may
move or face misfortune
[Music]
pass by your enemy hungry but never
naked
[Music]
judge by cause not by effect
what is written on the brow will
inevitably be seen by the eye
a house without a woman is like a
graveyard
grain must return to the earth die and
decompose for new growth to begin
learn politeness from the impolite
seek to perform your duties to your
highest ability
this way your actions will be blameless
[Music]
if you search for the laws of harmony
you will find knowledge
wise people are not overconfident they
put their trust in god
leave him an error who loves his error
a pupil may show you by his own efforts
how much he deserves to learn from you
when the angels appear the devils run
away
if you defy an enemy by doubting his
courage you double it
to teach one must know the nature of
those whom one is teaching
the man who is in the right has both
stature and the last word
not everything with a crooked neck is a
camel
evil as well as good both operate to
advance the great plan
[Music]
the monkey is as beautiful as a gazelle
in his mother's eyes
every man must act in the rhythm of his
time
wise people develop the disciplines of
honesty
diligence gentleness and humility
yesterday's drunkenness will not quench
today's thirst
he who gossips with you will gossip
about you
through its buzzing a wasp only ends up
bringing about the destruction of its
own nest
[Music]
altruism is the mark of a superior being
for the benefit of the flowers we water
the thorns too
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander
wise people seldom speak but when they
do
they speak words that are pleasing
rather than foolish
in his own nest a beatle is a sultan
better a warm welcome than an invitation
to lunch
[Music]
the only thing that is humiliating is
helplessness
[Music]
eat him for lunch before he eats you for
dinner
more precious than our children are the
children of our children
the best and shortest road towards
knowledge of truth is nature
[Music]
under the shakes hat is a monkey
[Music]
stretch your legs as far as your blanket
extends
one who cooks poison tastes it
you want what you want he wants what he
wants but god does what he wants
take the fare from him who is wealthy
and let pass him who is poor
[Music]
the woman who does not covet the
possessions of her husband is in love
with another man
whoever is ashamed to sleep with his
wife will never have children
a woman will be twice bound when her
chains feel comfortable
[Music]
you